you are about to become the biggest
brand in racing movie deals in
commercial product endorsements strip
down do you think you're famous now will
be rich beyond belief
mr. Serling what is this about your
legacy every time you lose damage
yourself I'm sorry your racing days are
coming to an end
and we can only hope that this race
today wasn't it last and I decide when
I'm done
how're you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's butyl there is this change man
you know what I do what I don't know I
got nothing
I am so excited to train you I like a
challenge
I call you my senior project a little
mod not a sad undergo the beach ate me
Jackson storms that a new record today
when he pulled off the fastest lap ever
recorded
how you seen the latest record storm
today even any thought we gonna clean
this is my last chance
Cruz laughs if I lose I never get to be
the begin don't fear failure be afraid
of not having the chance you have the
chip eight to watch you on TV flying
through the air
you seem so careless that wish I knew
what that felt like
[Music]
you'll never be as fast to store but you
can be smarter than him
Racing is the reward stop your chances
of winning are 95 points 2%
that way
you
you